thank you very much and welcome to break
room number free and how you arco disappoint
formats what the power of the cloud is
based on a real introduction of myself
what more important the wheel arches me
story of ruben kruid does he see you or
youngcapital funky very much for  your
nails vd grip starts
so i'm going to start interviews
interview where the cloud will import the least
and add google to achieve goals
and how i have planets in out day today
technology and howie collaborate in order
for all company's toe wmf males of
that's  so
my name is paul they also demand
each other creativity
google cloud and he more today it to
help you get any questions regarding
this die stop
so what we want to achieve this lost
product and what big-o toilet width to bring
2d
everyone to  teams closer so you
camouflage renko bigger than the
competition' every wat wat beautiful until the
speakers upgrade already confetti key and note
this morning
bills muiriel discover what
but more  important than data loon is why
did so important right now why was the
technology that be used for ten years i
als efficient in off to stay ahead of
the curve and to communicate to each
other day baby for use to realize that
no longer sufficient in off  -white the wie
niet hoe mijn faster than i should be
kas
baris in the group die technology brief
in startups site taking over the world
de becoming more and more and events
every day and the brick and more and
more powerful zoey have to act i like
this web so technology drifted in
startups
to stay and her or de coeur who has
intention so the last 17 years and we
want to help inspire you
hopefully you can jerry pack for my
dsm about to be pc culture is more
important and friend and technology  and
lonen
what we have learned from startups and for
my own organization is it freezings a
very important to remember
first of all we need er w's store
mission statement wooden organize the
world's information and ho  w to make it
universally accessible and useful
that the mission statement of google work
art literary works the same driving car
department if you work youtube of
google cloud everybody wants to organize
the world's information that star
motivation and were looking for people
partners and folds isco lies that  want
to continue to the same goal and sulfur
for that's a primary statements and the
company has its own reformation stab me
to focus on track the song transparency
helps such as to move quickly open
information there meeting is open en wie
vinken en wie ben ik en axis  information
and instep f3 is
pivotal for an ovation processes in
order to innovate becomes the sims peter s
disruptive technology floated in startups
you don't port quite open and transparent
culture en nv open and transparent
technology platform net wife and french
sole important and thirdly voice is
ready important
so everybody the organization net dc power
to create negative the creator product
wide new project and ex appel
de dijk en give you to date is based on
this you will look out with a view to you if
you have questions avoided idea
this is a very simple to use you simply
tap in that url you pay electrical site
your channel issue a deal see each
other questions and ruben en marcel full
of sir de top free issue indica ill
and like each other questions and the
question at heijmans like bol buy
billion comets to sir at the end
of this app has been so for a while
that something that uses wel wie google
f16 7000 employees in the meantime ohv
titi live every week
you know tgif rider frank google it's
friday
en on this friday bf presentation of die
angry asia osendarp on the club cio
and presenting it as to your strategy
of your  product
financial numbers en
Fout is of people are watching with live
stream rather use to and sending
questions to do speakers
af te word source en doen de
secretary en de
wel de called s and t things on the webquest
in being connect our home was a ton
with quite far we would the issue
and connect was
yes for the best interest on the speaker
in mosstime would be who the this
particular tool is even for her
recreate the website and colic and like
those crash  wifi tv democratic way to
get the best questions and rising toe the
top that costs per best ai direct and
came from anywhere
and that is the key man is that whoever lives
a cent in care in that sense is the
best idea and camp for me  new church
camp of the vice president in your
organization and check the vice president
and camp in shanghai potential penetrate
workshop
uncle as like clicks camp of sam
videos we contact you
customer feels the friction and console
something right way you wanted gifts
under the dead power and the muscle or
moment of the rider w-what is this is what and
nobles the cloud
wiha datacenters all over the world who
a vest about and billion dollars per
here in box datacenters
realizing  service this network is argon
fiber optic network roles in the planet
sorry the oil pump in the world that he is
always and fiber optic network
monastery square is this motif the customers
and the users on the mole
on the jokes for people of the app's
that you that fold of  her network and role
would that dia is that you use
regardless were here in tokyo or in a
jar en en over in the world you
go to have v-shirt letens die towards
the information ik als we ship the
information with you wherever you go
and it helps times the top notch
performance with cloud performance in
detail importance
so what is going home international
company study fan company's lifecode
chopping block poster
and and numerous other companies going
down based on competition of
disruptive technologies startups is
all about culture
for slade e see  information atween top
secret is running is great difficulty
accidents certain point of information
you don't the bait for permission juni de
certain  clearance level you don't have a lot
of time and effort
spent to get to the right information
and nette in ovation
pays of course zo your people in your
organization how er in die wet contact
richer customers has dt call of time
to figure out  what the right and
relevant information is then you're
ready to late in this example two days
or you're too slow
secondly what missy is dat and making
mistakes is being received a traditional
effect measurements kept falling to me is posting
pop something like this think it's very important
as this is the thermal culture of
psychological safety the people arno the
of peace of measurements more and more likely in
this digital day and age
smeking spends the schnappi expansion and
finally this track is piccola fat cat  and
the fat cat they yelled and they the say you
king power lines in the he was the view
international companies there already in you few
people in the organize in the he  ft
de power view
neato cs lewis shirt en energie tip en
dat but for two reasons and number one
that takes a lot of time together
theagenda features the morning ze
qualification nlse thoris pen derrick
review board and secondly it is a
stabicad people blow der project Oude
for porsche and he just doesn't talk
5000 dollars bad eyes only
projects sub-projects be gets
full 100 volts in order to get on the
edge and dag of this
fat cat and keyword and just like be
sat before your innovation
process becomes like working  Nieuwendijk the share
what you first of all those the weaknesses
technology two of organizing focus
on all the dating is online archive thing
is in the cloud
you can exquisit stainless steel at always a
nature of this app to technology driven
startups had to do in 15 om premise
hard  work their had in vest in
highly specialized technology and
technology people for that
infrastructure parten they realize an
information available in the evil
sure 3d image  er weaving primarily for
mobile thick if mobile is the user primer
user interface of of all your users vol
je consumers therefore also more welle
finds if you build and the app for an
der platform is not cooking bimo bouw
first
special ecards the mobile phone dat  is
a fine on the cpu we lang of the
mobile phone this is super mary i realize
of the big datacenters the google cloud
platform for instance
need you have you in our app francis
motor fire from the waiter have that a villa
in the cpu power of  i-phone intro lite
of the cpu power of the cloud gel clothing
reasoning cap driver is of percent it
is the possibilities a limit lesson week
as if this slave technology would
limitations is a your rank creativity in
the man with that you block it creativity
denyo  be slower than the competition and
that they see disaster
week that it was your wifi net at
kodak machine tap blok we blokbuster
a mix of companies that he effect it
the world and this royal shipping of fixed
he li  ke this place oh god this is the cbs
insight
slide it the unicorn clap your partner to
younico a clap review word about
trillion dollars and what cb insights that
ict projects is to timescale door
embedding backpack gray further on the
spot light light u a  focused on this
part
special i ran as becomes you can see is
that defining deed is projects tanis
timeline mr and it canning
increasingly crowded
mtb along i ran if you defects the tick
[ __ ] time to found a company that
recruit trillion dollars and that supports the
statement of their perfect disruptive
technology driven star guitar much event
and that sarlaccs competition regarde le
symbole check my job is just faster
and faster picasso of moore's law and
more flowey dan not by interviewing
this and ve10 mans the cpu quality bubbles
and the price have  rights watch fifty
percent of the eight someone in the
house like that since the intention of
the personal computer but ibm and there
people s  ay ok be as county continuous
the simplest boot stilt happens
so why they keep the cut the
technology experts so incredibly jump
so what does not hurt and google is who
trends members it ar learning types
last 17 years into a couple of
investment' vinisce that we have  to be
aware of the man with the pr account to be
more productive front full whose
focus to the teams that the most import
separate culture part you want to make it
tool set
that allows them to work real time to
give him the feeling that their  working
and small teams together to foster who
dip in disconnect in six piccolo
tedsters or find them version you didn't see it
not for those super secure
people nothingness feeling that whenever
they work we all device
there is no risk of information getting
laid the coast apple
that that they these [ __ ] effects number
one
thirdly is bio unproductive that that
people access to help you do more with
less times and of course the cosby quite
reelly but b  elief in the bad guy they can
come for many were i want to create the
platform word brand customers and
partners can build upon
quality to the database visor it more
apps of a net word and image
its even so the platform  is where you
import and usability
is is pivotal and that something
that you will never eton
maize verroost not for real
revenue winnetou special made since you
develop something that doesn't require
manuel
for billion people see you we they
don't need to download the me now or
first oh local youtube move your
en roll for training ben de product is
then the product is
is a success that surprised to brush roll
and that where usability is so
import it who would produc studay
this who lift the sheets two of this
principle
is not wit him in a vacuum what they
the forest id  ee that you can youse de baby
en bij that this knowledge of the art
culture in this is what who specifically
line this mamie start image google.com
in miso dati
tools dhabi skin to communicate for not
sufficient in to get advice dan af
they were  too expensive and require to
much
backbone technologies to van anne en
that while i developed by jees sweet and
that's what i have brought to the
enterprise mark
to work teams since full
and melted ivf payoff kalki members r2f
avoid the moment you become
primitive partner is going to be
exponential higher productivity them in
your katie minus separate
leather lang are you work form of so
where who because there were by the full  to
work india on facebook erge that not all
with possible because people work across
the cloud is dat dad waw i created porex
met high resolution and met je is like
hangout to ensure people de  world to
work together and see if they were
working next to each other
the
meeting rooms for you and me' this
weekend in club meeting room she book
meeting rooms and happy feeling that you
together eventhough jurgen worlds
des anges number trainer team drive is
something kph interviews
recently that encourage you to check wat
bossche bollen team drive team gripe  cc
folder a fragment where you able to
share information with each other
beyoncé your own ownership so in the
plate who it i-drive folder and you
become owner and the moment you love
company
the documents for only to be accessed by
the administrative instance nou  who
has team price that all out you to use
drives you would use fausia friend
sisters is one folder apf drive and
everybody can find it in the easy life
updates to what p what we do about google
sites like this ferry sees something like this create
internet sites and the update it all the
time and it's always be very secure
image arno and security level slide
driver this morning or
whether it becomes julia zoë f7 and this morning i
of politics
one billion users' something hoe haag the
various times so that she her jean faktor
or as batman the many questions the
briquettes thai curry in africa are
in the cloud and it spread out all over
the world how to my my datasafe
door more than happy to go  in composé ze
million in title where this image
appliqués who he from propriety hardware
who wants a datacenter young
klaas peper cry for cables who
control of and that effect in haiti and that
blows details so super safe what who
specifically because the focus on  is fishing
for instance that what do you see as pores
benefit mobile management databases or
personal horse so you see if you
please back and coverage
what is the front and te tomorrow prob  loam
I love it you use chef en net where
we have this program
then help users to be more secure
automatically with friend since the
security key so irritating not in
artipico the anymore simply
something that you have some 10 dat juno
en bad it in one  device and then your
free to go mobile device management is
very important brief die plicat dat
recently with the entire dutch national
police force do you want to do the mobile
device management for them they haven't'
her risk anything here since so far
very happy to have  them and partner at
reference
for the for the future and there be
can help them or dit and it the deta
usually a configuration and critters and
never did no longer the technique lee
also did it roll the garden
first party apps as part of their and
there  is the platform where everybody can
image afterparty you can easily
epia integration particle platform became such a
topper
with the gmail icons for instance you can
integrate it for the other apps  that
might be very useful for you
for your activity safety net is is
is is pivotal for getting the most out
of your employees
wie apply machine learning to get to
increase the productivité wie help you
get smart work life will help you with
setting  a replay already we that third
man with that you receive an e-mail
that you do not rain on class also and
the mail is just in the cq we love or
timing the timing calendar is already such a
no-brainer paul that work  on to in test
over time is already there in by being
in the tropics the possibility wit
white with microsoft a nice one come you
wrote short presented because the show
you will hippe but your show this
morning presentation about
spreadsheets where this live demo
keep it xlii works in detail quickly
setup hey bro
ken de camping auf der ton screen zo die
is bizarre a couple of roos en columns
based on sales information and like bill
hip reaper en dan de hero and coding
en maar de her  o a spreadsheet
management show they simply design this
button here
he go to explore and a professional
references
what is the average
cost of i you
and it start gel clothes and get old
and new rep.set it for diet
sixty-six ever upgrade iso takes  to the
context from the minute lee helps with
allah is big chunks of detail' become
atmi being an expert can i go back to
the presentation
and that helps as already leave beer
products on the street the debit also not
special
training atmosphere that he adwise youtube  is
the cem board
third jamboree many bol in to youtube
play around with this is actually is a
white board that you us but and is
interactive free key user costs planet
earth and all john bord sign
glossing sap and live at stake last
exam polder there because  the give you
is the is i de de ar search and bilities
dpf implemented in a product that first
she de man that je use google wheel and
able you to search especially the documents
like your use the corner  google rights
wit op de mol church to work i miss in your
life te fact dokkum is much for faster
than you were used in in second sea
level the relevant information at je als
that were gone to based on the context
base of the device using both  on your
next calendar entry
i want to yodeling the those
documents that riots find for you
so the currently you have calendar and
feel richer colic is down to get all
the document you recently geert know
that specific leggings you can percent
it  with it ages that the light and it can
to save you a lot of time and get you
alone of more value nice
a roof old fireworks and the choir google
cloud search
so this comes through a trial your
productivity massively
and this is the last one want to share  with
you on the drive
sharefile it becomes platform it actually
synchronize is all the fail that your hair
from your logo machine
up in the cloud be at you having to
worry about your fuller dump [ __ ]
that you use would it help  the usability
massive I ran if you do not really
need to explain all at in en en wat
spots new and the other and vine met
for people or not use to work with
we gmail frinstance die sar de roadmap
implementation stepper I hope
diplomas to do
the king the queen cords the reason
why show this is that google is bing
pc version consumer product
since la fere who has my research into
and enterprise ready
company we focus and enterprise is
my dear and that means who has
those beautiful products full of products  bos
be used to be used to dedicate an
application bambi dit een synapse
traction and the consumer world and the
enterprise partners of arms were used to
working with zo'n lisa this application
disappear and they were to in it in
trouble zo
deadshot pr change the  promise that if
applications will be there you are able
to anticipate because they coming and what's
next to help you to run you organize
you must be professional what you expect
from mi  jn professional enterprise
company will be like this keeps sieur d'arques
you would like to thank you for
listening to my story the
astoria seems to be the patient review print card
video of young capital in ireland we
ran ass the ok
expensive for words but keep  if it xlii
work
times wants to camp die youngcapital tv
but I think you bas
was new management at jan kaper osb
and respect it costs her unlike
other it back to say that
backstage were highly respected supply
for as much as complement you but get
laid back  and the army in the
presentation at very important factor
so different it would you more about the
transition that would it to load the
sweet little more by kangol you might
work force microscope were that active
campaigning
listen we base nina parliament etc
how access for 15 years  from fireplace
to the
in those online channels to many
we focus on the young couple
of the netherlands' fine with johnny so
who is getting over the white ram what mi  jn
heart empirical to volume locations and
were pretty young company
energizer population is twenty five
again so on that i think to the staff
were too as and how do you say such a series
we have grill or
sexy typical glacier and we push in dc
thing  the surgeon and so this seriously
lesson series challenge so
therefore wie es die action de parme just
such a challenge' studies how not to
find ways to make this company
future-proof
opinion new york to work completely
online that makes is flexible
maxxis het display  quickly to market
english speakers this young population
to bumi for it was also my first
live well change as long as we are
so tired next to external factors into this
funny way to integrate with their
applications and
versafine reporter this feature ideal en
ships
what may be more important  and that's
why compliment you
is find no way to find a company that
really feature who had in an opinion
enter a for partner we week en
conca d'oro know so degr  veins
such a word hard anaa week does its
thing
therefore but the focus on the
technical aspects of is of this
transition and green no more by dr
key features of reactive partner then
did the technival
impact analysis and the transition and
migration
you can one side  i live with him
because this is the more about change
management because you changing the
tools
the tour look of the people of your people
were they work on a daily base oh this
high impact that that means
dress you changing the way they work on a
daily base
person for the cause it's about change
management
my first prizes haier en experts zo
die never say never done this before in
the picos is so high high impact
for that how your earth company us dollar
at best practices for my company en de
lydia great job  for as so that the fortress
on because you to advise of this is the w
vd the sims apes
want things because how much i focus on is
the fur black
what's in it for me because that's
really important  meaning
what are these for the company where I do
the number crunching you do here your
business case because of this the technical
analysis
what this is this sum that I in the case
wit wit
you have to say with this is about changing
the talk the tool set of people  working
how to do this then the daily base
what's in it for me is very important
an after the van tab too warm
some of heat tab so what doesn't matter
who wins work for and detective a
number use cases where the power find
work of  strings in the processes
and wie detected and we make sure that
became his goal for dry comb petting
zoo
first video of sephora use cases where
we where we find grill pan strange
[Music]
i actually use my inbox as me
to do list that if i  an inbox
so you can they have to
think about it phone from another fish
and then it costs you a lot of time and to be the public there again
yes for the first time a new one has to
log in then I think
you knew about it  tier over do it before I
can reach it and certainly in my entrance via
here I have to know it is
occasionally a lot of things you about
obscure places on sleeping difficult because
someone from his mobile my world and
I answer can my signature  you do not mind
if I receive a scan from
scanning device and I want to forward it
carnatic not under that sort of thing that
is annoying start working with telephony
from on you a large screen michael is
here but that does not always work
also gives you from thiev in  entertained
yourself sent tourists that that
mainly
good work and old
I play a game of helps belt eines
find mails to country of in my mails
and species
knew could strike the imposing
target is being
ready for so much time to fresh go your
mail well  kill
no my grandma knew china against that frog
gmail what what province is there of gmail
there of china that was on-site catch ya the
fun park ds of course that i want you go
into y  our company in us met people
do the rework then your komodo and rinca
people really great and function
bypasses
but also you experience meteor add
using in have in the private life trunk
tools google ready provider so get in
it for more leds your thumb thumb thumb
use  cases have fransepad stranger i
found their way
huawei on the right side of the
business case yet but were syria serious
games for the company just the company but
only for the company but for the people
doing the workshop is improving
just like you will via company slept living
the life you up makes sense here's
a variety of use cases to
take one a fair your stuff must be
significant so is
starting do you have computer francis
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[  Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I am
[Applause]
[Music]
some bacon in the rally preselection
frisomat from many people is this
recognizable situation and  i think
confuse people to the season were
time and i in proof of would you the
de of finish would this was by sleep
of all use cases that the third
the ramp of the research keep it so we
the were
fine allo allo I pick some aspects  or
the procedure drivers of
training your style proverbs
knowing what you said you guys it's
a pupper planning take your time for
another way counting the most crucial
factor was igoogle heroes zo door who
who who who this is
select people i just as for who wants  to
fall en charlie je flyer
be coming google giro en het
Deze training porn inspector that means people are intrinsically motivated to be imposeur of the snow
new new product en zo did van
de work for you a few cares for
promoting and new way of working  a
new toolset
which is crucial
vector in the success of app and successfully
change
additionally beetle larvae tent the
special user groups
the arsan media excel wizards way  en
company mee minion financial
department de the case frame sensor
what do the core different or you or or the
word de no ar so you still there to
make sure that you give them a special
attention and show them
media new way of working help them  find
new way of working and editing is something
like oil you build it technical
translation is already such a moment or van
mieke's you you you changing the way of
working what is or so en momentum dat your
license plate
to see what we were to the [ __ ]  libri
can do it in a very nicely
so der for the project team splash
seats
the google here is make it work that
really important
the rocks to another major effect is
let you and by c1000 management so
between 6 and that we measure how from  it
do it
there's no way back who can really
make it work and dog and make it work in
a way that people of so need
copies of projects with my best
pictures so
ivf reggy basement a eunuch make it
again who wants it would  your bed
this is keep your process off the board to
really make sure we can go into
poor sorrow
drink what in the water
angie
desk your computer the om warm white
boys sat kilo ok see you bye
how
do i take care all alone now all i have to do with everything
go  the boys
[Music]
and that's how we're going to do it
okay girls good things hangouts
nice so success
[Music]
in 2017 about keeping cool how you
yes
has
good she all kinds of
yes living and fight and for size that
really bring something new and  the
junior company and gilly the show that
from from the tab too warm for the
heat the language
there is also one there is already success
story nootdorp right coating with your walking
chip so
princess liard it and she kimono and although
in her channel so the  put the google
here vso de der door
magical chase there people s him would his
son petticoat agree was
your email signature i was really mean
you're in a company such a gate and
team dynamics
week advice and alarm emails dollar
peopl  e rid anyway nice marketing tool
for asus pudding gateway to the word the
who knows your
chipie we know the right the the de
found that waymarsh and about online show
yes you had that we box tanks pony
important matters
the right party them again
the groups eurostar  crucial and this
book is in a formula d oh help get
outside for a while hobbies
attracts creations
so were mist and now i'm fine in bikini
on percentage take your time
who's seriously agree to my er or
rushing it before the end tank something
against  maud
tree for months at least to make sure
that you go into a quote change
manager management process
nathalie doen your technique on facebook
mixer marketing communications even
head and your setup de rai channels
make sure that you take your time to van
your google heroes  and can have it
so hdd go wild area where required by the
evil
lang we in the process
whether or technical issues but
straight leather navi know about for
percent for mailbox is  typical white again
and
because wie dit migration
de first work they know we've already
sold as you can
de special interest groups were yet to
focus on them because we've found out
that some of them or het net mers
have it  also website look in this
park was that we our fans and processes
within fit large x or desk
little love is processes socks so how
it no third both servers i it
these kinds of sites ipad from going to
the seconds transitions
social the summer allah making  de
kroes shows actors
series see this process texting change
management project and make sure that
you get people work at shirley's take
time for for enough change with the
party and tag your garden
who is that that is serious process
the murder davy linie to endorse  this
program the gas induction do you dive into a
win-win-win in the people manager company
then the people do well the work
bobby dat foto s people numbers times
within this presentation
the google heroes de  essential so
ambassadors find them find the forensic
limo the fader
to help you with er zo the special user
groups
can in your keeper the demo tension door
premium gate it in though my
mind change work
enter marcom min x 11 de wright
channels to communicate on  a de
frequent en bosons on a love for
visual level and communicate then i paint
him and last but not least i to
something is the change during king
trial lesson or je kampen of people en i
test in the production en
and do you working within your  company so
before that will such moments
vibration make sure that she presented in
a very far away
so so what is but your percentage
driver
is carried to was i get so
much eye candy that we tooth rings view
matter that pvc from you thank you  very
much so that's six in was monastery well
so week and weekend thumb up a few
questions at the most beautiful that's how the
slides beer many promises of chippie
scroll up de narsingh the number one
question brood  transparency
ball toe is
hello bob bob posters amber de you'll be
able to find it may be interesting
partners ianden getting started my
linkedin page pipe and llorenc tympanum
are referenced all their pin up is also an
ex what is the
see the  videos on the defini use cases
server interesting to see how to make
sure that easy view to find this light
the pockets of where thousands of gee sweet
have politics the setup polly's for
in since to access management also
pasafoor poesjes
know that he there you have  a
review her that the business view for
instance you can set up and sp enterprise
you can help you vast majority of
setting spray a push things like
out or so in mobile device management
princess week a love baby also did
red shirt and user groups
you can  copy all the settings for may
your active directory settings and become
you had it in the past
has out of a thousand cola de medically for
what we are whatsoever doumbia for
partners like
ruben already ment  ioned app will help you
setup it super
easy to do laundry
and also who food is more expensive
the other questions for the poor whites
oil promotion for three solid a good
bam there is hot in secret
in the garcia so google is it technology
company or not out
good at marketing you be who lives
cyril ate in the financial newspaper by
it it's about like to be relevant
bucket like to be found the man with that
you think its relevance something in the in
the nature or google
offer to ebola novelty with that
google.com more android hyder
you know if because it have users
communicated to each other
yes i just thumpy derby cheese ok maybe
not at fysio in de promotion
when your hands lodge er in contact
with google
they have never very interesting program
for companies to make  sure that you well
i have get another tool scanner
applications free smoothing or something by
providing vouchers for the transition
cost french a kind
rather creative in ball with his win
fertilizers  wheels' can yes and also around
the buildings on the magi
so before that yes i think that this one that
stayed there morning
jets jets green people to work shop pro
league is there a while your product what
went with it is very easy for for for you to
to  to the transition to the toe to poke
in zo
interest igari secure mobile device in
temse mentioned management and policy
province thinks so has your product for
that be in fiji suite and breadth is
mobile device manager at each week and n
roll your mobile device that you  warn't
our iphones that is mather
android devices you had waymarsh
settings and incense that tuck iphones in
her in her
sweet where it still possible on top of
that ef android for work and that's
mobile application management and
economy op poes
applications and its debut part  veert is
that other than usual
mobile application management something
you can outside that box arcon trainer
points
opinion the manager in the container
wanted your connections information nigh  t just about
beaver dan weer Trotsdoos application
zodiac occasion die just in beach
friends normal application the phone of
the user
and who says members like en toe the
kind de icann of is sweet case and that
enables us ekompany to communicate to
user dat we easy to  recognize boxes ar
company policy
pushes en en boxes apps hai just download
much for ever the user user is himself in c
you may be there yourself week and it is that fold
the kind of mobile application management
and mobile device management say
we are different that also be  cause this
tammeling you do not allow joke that jaap
anymore third party apps on real hard to
repte mal with this you want to get into
we container that we just used the ptr used to
working with wdd futures for the min that
google app store you create your  own
google app store for your company and
then you can push and i am also offer
party apps available
so insist ef anythin' specific issue
and so the context way dennis i was
in holwerd out put it  in their to
check of death why were you normally
like this
we running at the end of the percentage
army for a while she is the top
free for you must agree that led tv
marge you are [ __ ] you very much for
coming and
looking for to  be working with you in
the future
[Applause]